[Music]
Andy I know his move has been really
tough but this was supposed to be a new
start for us remember you said you were
gonna try to make you focus buddy can
connect to and control all of your
castle and products and smart home
devices introducing your new best
friends
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow I need to tell you something and I
need you to read me I think Chucky did
something and if you know something you
better tell me
something's wrong with Chucky buddy can
connect you and control all of Chucky is
a toy this could be anywhere welcome to
Casa link are
[Music]
we have to stop him
[Music]
hi Daddy
[Music]
over here outside
I think Chucky did something to her
sweetie
Chucky is a toy okay
it broke God mom I saw him I saw him
following green no you didn't listen to
what you're saying well he's gonna kill
her Chuck why aren't you listening to me
I have it on all Worstell he's following
green I I can tell you why do you have
Omar's phone I took it I why I had to
write I had to follow Chucky mom okay
I'm not crazy mom stay right here okay
and you're coming to work with me he's
trying to kill us
listen if you know something you better
tell me
I'm really excited about playing the
role of Karen the idea of playing a
young single mom was really appealing to
me honestly just to work with Gabriel
and Brian I think both of them are
incredible actors who are you
detective Mike Mike is very loyal and
very trustworthy he's a police officer
he meets this little kid Andy who really
doesn't have any friends I know that
people have probably been talking to you
about me but I don't believe everything
you hear
Andy he's more mature than most kids his
age I would say and he has a hearing aid
which makes him pretty insecure so he
doesn't really socialize much you said
you were gonna try to make new friends
and she gets really attached to Chucky
because he's really vulnerable actually
lies is dope he is ready to play his
vision is awesome
he has a dry sense of humor so you can't
really tell when he's joking
he's bringing his Scandinavian military
background to set I'm just on high alert
at all times it's definitely more than
intensified on this set there's a creepy
dark undercurrent I just think it's
great
this is Chucky this is about Chucky
as soon as I saw this I just jumped at
it reading the sights I was pretty sure
dad's play so it was off the bat as you
can say I have never been more excited
to be a part of anything then child's
play
see how much fun we have buddy can
connect to and control all of your
canceling products and smart home
devices introducing your new best friend
the message of technology is evil is
really relevant they're one of the most
talked about topics in technology physis
arles more and more accidents are being
caused by a I trusted devices now my
phone is talking to me now appliances go
on and off it's terrifying a series of
accidents involving self-driving car
killing a family of five in 2019 Chucky
a smart ways to kill ease
he's not no evil in the beginning you
see him become evil throughout the story
[Applause]
Chucky's evolves more and more but not
in a good way
[Music]
and action he is such an iconic
character
something that you don't ever forget
this doll is able to hold his own in the
pantheon of horror the idea that Chuck
is a smart dog
maybe this movie is foreshadowing
everything is in a cloud now even the
adults are susceptible to the child's
play over at all Chucky I thought most
of it was gonna be CGI but they had like
an animatronic doll 6 that moved and
could make facial expressions and
everything when I saw the Chucky doll I
was kind of impressed how realistic he
looks how he can convey emotion a big
part of getting Chucky writers having
animatronics be a lot of the times that
we see Chucky CSEC become alive has been
very rewarding it's a difficult process
to make him animatronic puppet could get
this beautiful design transfer it onto
the ball the actual Chucky dolls the
internal structure is a series of
animatronics and help move all the
joints it has a plastic exoskeleton we
put over top of the animatronics
the skins are made of foam latex eyes
will be replaced with digital movement
and then we dress this costume over top
of that we call him our Robo chat it
usually takes three to four full
puppeteers simply to talk about space
has a little expression in it don't
forget your little doll you can got
interchangeable hands that are just
pretty and grabbing ha it's an Evo robot
there's nothing creepier than that
[Music]